Hernández vive en esta zona rural del
Estado Miranda tiene 26 años y cuatro
hijos es una de las decenas de mujeres
afectadas en el sector por la denominada
pobreza menstrual la inflación que
persiste en Venezuela le impide acceder
a toallas sanitarias y productos de
higiene durante el ciclo menstrual no sé
cómo voy a hacer ahorita cuando me
vengan la menstruación
aunque a veces me tengo que poner trapo
a veces a veces me irrito y me tengo que
estar lavando con con Montes casero como
dice la gente
katiuska no tiene acceso regular al agua
potable en su comunidad en el mejor de
los casos el agua llega Por tubería cada
15 o 20 días a veces no reciben el
servicio durante meses lo que complica
aún más su higiene personal
por aquí tu esposo yo a veces todo que
vas a buscar agua por allá abajo que si
para lavar y si para cocinar para bañar
a los niños en la misma población las
hermanas misioneras de turba y la ong
acción por Venezuela suministran kits
para la higiene menstrual de madres de
niños que alimentan en un comedor social
Ana una de las beneficiarias cuenta que
en este sector las mujeres tampoco
tienen como adquirir los medicamentos
para aliviar los dolores menstruales con
la cuestión de las pastillas hay que
salir una hora y media a comprarlas en
otra parte porque por acá no las venden
según el más reciente informe auspiciado
por el instituto de prensa y sociedad la
pobreza menstrual en Venezuela aumentó
en 40% se trata de una realidad
silenciosa que activistas de
organizaciones no gubernamentales como
Janette Moreno intentan visibilizar para
llamar la atención de las autoridades
Consideró que hacen falta políticas
públicas Considero que falta educación
Considero que se tiene que atender
porque la higiene menstrual es sumamente
importante porque evita enfermedades
mientras que en Venezuela la pobreza
menstrual sigue siendo un tema sin
atención en países como Colombia y en
México se han adelantado políticas
públicas para abordar el problema como
exonerar de impuesto al valor agregado a
los tampones toallas sanitarias y copas
menstruales a manera de facilitar a
mujeres y niñas el acceso a estos
productos de primera necesidad